Heyeveryonedogan
hereUMSoIspeakany
Japanesebutrecently
onTwitterIseenalot
ofvideosofpeople
usingAItokindofmake
themselvesspeak
otherlanguagesSoI
thoughtItryanddothe
sameThingwith
Japaneseandina
secondwegnadothatto
thisveryVideoWhatdo
youthinkareyou
impressed
disappointedLetme
knowUMWhatELseIam35
yearsoldAmericanand
bornandraisedInThe
StateOf
washington
ガIknowinthenear
futurelovetovisit
JapanIReallyWantTo
SeeThetemplesthe
shinesandjustkind
experienceThe
richnessOfThe
cultureANDTHE
HISTORY
handokIthinkwaitto
seeHowITturnsOUT皆さん
こんにちは同ですアニメと変態が大好き
ですえっと僕は日本語ができませんが最近
Twitterで多くの人たちがAIを
使ってこう外国語を喋っている自分の映像
を作ったり波や夜などアニメキャラクター
のエロ映像を作ったりしているのを見て
自分もやってみたいなと思いましたえっと
そしてこの後この映像を使ってそのテスト
の一部を行いたいと思っていますえ皆さん
どうですか最近早々のフリーレを見てい
ますかそれとも進撃の巨人を見ていますか
あ僕も両方ですあとはなんだろうええ僕は
35歳でアメリカ人でえ人生の半分以上を
オタクとして過ごしていますあ
洗顔今日調子悪いなえっと近いうちに日本
に行ってみたいです特に日本のコンビニと
日本人女性を生で見てそれから渋谷の
スクランブル交差店で自撮りをしたいなと
思っていますはいえ以上だと思います
ちなみに僕は
です